lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar acerca de la núcleo felicidad
núcleo
creo felicidad si lee see that núcleo
felicidad y esto lo único que es es que
está núcleo filo es un átomo o una
molécula o un millón que yo voy a
escribir aquí una definición la núcleo
felicidad es la habilidad
habilidad
de un átomo
átomo guión
jon o molécula como
lectura es la habilidad de un átomo jon
o molécula para
regalar un electrón extra regalar
regalar un electrón
extra
y formar un enlace
por más
cool enlaces
enlace que nuclea felicidad es la
habilidad de un átomo o molécula para
regalar un electrón extra y formar un
nuevo enlace con el núcleo de algún otro
átomo y eso es lo que la palabra núcleo
filo significa que le gustan los núcleos
aquí especialmente los que tienen una
carga positiva y si queremos identificar
un muy buen núcleo filo debería de tener
electrones extras que los buenos núcleos
y los tienen
tienen electrones extra
l
drones extra
extra que pueden regalar y que pueden
regalar
y las mejores cosas que tienen
electrones extras que pueden regalar son
los iones negativos aunque ahí los
aniones y en un nivel muy alto tenemos
al flúor que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
electrones pero es súper electro
negativo y muy fácilmente le puede
quitar uno de sus electrones a otro
átomo convirtiéndose en el avión
fluoruro y esto pasa muy fácilmente con
todos los halógenos aquí así como el
flúor se convierte en el fluoruro el
cloro se convierte en el cloruro el
bromo en el bromuro y el yodo en el
yoduro aunque bueno vamos a poner algún
otro halógeno pongamos por ejemplo el
yodo tenemos aquí el yodo que tiene
muchos más electrones que el flúor pero
sólo tiene 7 electrones de valencia
ok 12
3 4 5 6 7 electrones de valencia pero
aunque el yodo no es tan electro
negativo como el flúor recuerda que que
está en el electro negativo es un átomo
aumenta así hacia arriba y hacia la
derecha así es que el yodo es menos
electro negativo que el flúor pero de
todas formas el yodo si es
suficientemente electro negativo como
para quedarse con el electrón de algún
otro átomo y convertirse en un unión con
su carga negativa y convertirse en un
yoduro y en general las cosas que tengan
carga negativa y pares de electrones
sueltos esas cosas van a ser muy buenos
núcleos filos y otro ejemplo de un buen
núcleo filo que no sea un halógeno es el
'angel hidróxido aunque ya demás es una
molécula lo que tenemos es un hidrógeno
unido a un oxígeno con sus dos pares de
electrones y bueno generalmente cuando
tenemos una molécula de agua tenemos
esto aquí
otro hidrógeno por aquí ahora el oxígeno
es un átomo muy electro negativo
entonces puede llegar y quitarle su
electrón al hidrógeno y quedárselo y
entonces lo que tenemos aquí está el
hidrógeno enlazado con el oxígeno que
tiene sus dos pares de electrones
originales tiene este electrón de aquí
pero además se quedó con este electrón
que antes era del hidrógeno así es que
ahora tiene una carga negativa y tiene
un electrón demás y bueno también nos
queda este hidrógeno pero ahora tiene
una carga positiva y en realidad este
hidrógeno sin su electrón es simplemente
un protón flotando por ahí pero bueno y
esto de aquí ahora es el a nyon
hidróxido ahora todos estos son unos
excelentes núcleo filos porque tienen
una carga negativa y tienen electrones
extra que pueden regalar sin embargo lo
que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es
pensar en cuál de estos excelentes
y los es más núcleo filo que el otro y
aquí las diferencias son un simple matiz
pero bueno lo que vamos a hacer es
comparar a estos núcleos filos en una
solución práctica y luego volver a
compararlos pero ahora en una solución a
práctica entonces primero vamos a ver
qué pasa cuando tenemos un solvente
práctico
frente práctico
pero tico realmente práctico y después
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando tenemos un
solvente práctico
la mente
práctico pero rico y solvente práctico y
estas pues son palabras muy elegantes
pero realmente significan algo súper
sencillo cuando tenemos un solvente
práctico es porque hay algunos
hidrógenos que pueden ser arrebatados o
cuando tenemos protones flotando en la
solución y el solvente práctico más
sencillo aunque bueno más bien creo que
es el solvente práctico más común es el
agua aunque tenemos aquí un oxígeno con
dos hidrógenos y sus dos pares de
electrones libres y por qué es éste un
solvente práctico pues porque puede
suceder esta misma reacción que tengo
dibujada aquí ok en cualquier instante
una molécula de agua le puede robar uno
de sus electrones al hidrógeno y
convertirse en un a nyon
hidróxido o también puede suceder que la
misma molécula de agua llegue y le robe
uno de sus hidrógenos a otra molécula de
agua y se vuelva un hidro nio que
tenemos aquí en nuestra molécula de agua
y tenemos un protón
dando en la solución con su carga
positiva y puede llegar este oxígeno y
regalarle uno de sus electrones a este
hidrógeno y se forma un hidro nio pero
en esta molécula en el libro no estos
hidrógenos están básicamente flotando
por ahí porque el oxígeno es muy electro
negativo y aquí tiene una carga positiva
y quiere recuperar uno de sus electrones
lo antes posible ok un solvente práctico
es el agua y en el agua vamos a ver
moléculas de agua y de repente vamos a
ver moléculas de hidrógeno y en iones
hidróxido y protones flotando por ahí
pero el chiste es que hay hidrógeno que
pueden interactuar con otras moléculas
aunque ya hay protones flotando en la
solución y listos para interactuar ahora
déjame borro esta molécula para tener
más espacio y escribo simplemente agua
agua y no sólo el agua es un solvente
práctico también cualquier alcohol es un
solvente práctico y tal vez me preguntes
que si ese es siempre el caso porque si
en el agua hay protones pareciera que en
todos lados hay protones flotando por
ahí pero no claro que hay solventes o
prácticos por ejemplo el de útil éter
aquí el cual se ve así tenemos aquí un
oxígeno con sus dos cadenas de tilo gay
se h 2c h 3 y por aquí otro se h 2
ch3 es un éter porque tenemos aquí un
oxígeno y dos cadenas de carbonos y es
de steele porque aquí tenemos esta
cadena de etilo y esta otra cadena
estilo y bueno aquí puedes decir que ahí
tenemos un montón de hidrógenos pero
estos hidrógenos están enlazados a
carbonos y el carbono no está en electro
negativo como el oxígeno el carbono no
es suficientemente electro negativo como
para quitarle su electrón a los
hidrógenos así es que todos estos
hidrógenos no van a terminar flotando en
la solución
si los hidrógeno se estuvieran enlazados
con el oxígeno entonces sí podría haber
protones flotando por aquí pero no
sucede así ok
por acá tenemos las moléculas de agua
y los alcoholes alcohol tenemos aquí a
un alcohol y bueno en un solvente
práctico como el agua o el alcohol pues
aquí tenemos estos hidrógenos que están
enlazados a un oxígeno que es muy
electro negativo entonces este oxígeno
si se puede quedar con el electrón de
estos hidrógenos y que el resto del
hidrógeno o sea el protón esté flotando
en la solución y bueno esta fue una
buena revisión de lo que es un solvente
práctico y práctico
y pensemos en los núcleos y los esta es
como una regla general lo que sucede es
que si un núcleo filo es propenso a
reaccionar con su solvente entonces en
esa solución no es un buen núcleo filo
ok pero piénsalo o sea si el núcleo filo
reacciona con el solvente entonces no va
a poder regalar con facilidad sus
electrones a la molécula a la que se los
tiene que regalar que piensa en una
reacción sn dos entonces lo que pasa con
los solventes prácticos es que si
tenemos un núcleo filo muy electro
negativo y pequeño como el flúor aquí
tenemos el flúor con sus siete
electrones de valencia 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
electrones de valencia pero en realidad
queremos pensar en el fluoruro así es
que tiene un electrón de masas y una
carga negativa ahora
el fluoruro es muy electro negativo y
además está empacado de una forma muy
compacta
el flúor tiene 9 electrones por ejemplo
si comparamos al fluoruro con el yoduro
el yoduro tiene muchísimos más
electrones
el yoduro tiene 54 electrones 53 del
yodo más un electrón extra tiene muchos
orbitales llenos de electrones mientras
que el flúor tiene únicamente 9
electrones de los cuales siete son
electrones de valencia y por lo tanto el
fluoruro tiene 10 electrones 9 del flúor
y 1 extra
así es que el fluoruro es mucho más
pequeño y si por ejemplo lo tenemos en
una solución de agua con moléculas de
agua flotando por ahí y pues este
oxígeno es mucho más electro negativo
que el hidrógeno por lo cual tiene una
carga parcial negativa y este hidrógeno
tiene una carga parcial positiva ok
este solvente es un solvente polar
volar y este de aquí también es un
solvente polar
polar porque el oxígeno sigue siendo más
electro negativo que estos carbonos
entonces el oxígeno tiene una carga
parcial negativa y los carbonos tienen
una carga parcial positiva que reparten
a lo largo de toda esta cadena de
carbonos así es que este hidrógeno tiene
una carga parcial positiva y se siente
atraído por la carga negativa del flúor
ok se forma un enlace por puente de
hidrógeno y eso está sucediendo todo
alrededor del fluoruro esto está
formando una especie de cáscara
alrededor del fluoruro lo cual hace que
sea difícil que reaccione con alguna
otra cosa
qué
reacciones de acción con alguna otra
molécula así es que ya no es tan buen
núcleo filo y por eso va a ser un núcleo
filo menos bueno que por ejemplo el
yoduro digamos que tenemos aquí el
yoduro y los electrones de valencia del
yoduro pues van a estar como por acá
ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 porque tiene todos
los otros electrones aquí en medio y
este electrón es el que le robó a otro
átomo
ahora el yoduro también va a estar
haciendo enlaces de puente de hidrógeno
con las moléculas de agua en esta
solución práctica pero ahora el yoduro
no está empacado de una forma tan
compacta y además
este yoduro es polarizar
hola
se hable porque el yoduro tiene toda su
masa de electrones por aquí y entonces
los electrones de valencia están
bastante alejados del núcleo y entonces
son más influenciables por otras
moléculas y así es más fácil que
reaccionen digamos por ejemplo que se
acerca a un carbono que está enlazado
con un átomo de bromo y entonces este
carbono tiene otros tres hidrógenos
pero como ya hemos visto este bromo es
más electro negativo que el carbono
entonces tiene una carga parcial
negativa y este carbono tiene una carga
parcial positiva y entonces este yoduro
que tiene sus electrones de valencia muy
lejos del núcleo como estamos en una
solución práctica la nube de electrones
del yodo se va a sentir atraída por esta
carga positiva y entonces se va a
deformar más o menos así y por lo tanto
va a ser más fácil que reaccione ok pero
esto sucede sólo si estamos en una
solución práctica mientras que el
fluoruro que está empacado de una forma
muy compacta va a ser mucho más difícil
que reaccione pero si nos vamos a ver la
tabla periódica
si estamos en una solución práctica y
nos fijamos en los saludos que son los
guiones negativos de los halógenos el a
nyon yoduro sería el mejor núcleo filo
en un solvente práctico mientras que el
anillo
sería el menos núcleo a filo de todos
estos saludos entonces en una solución
polar práctica
obsesión volar volar práctica
practica el alumno más núcleo filo es el
yoduro yo duro y después el siguiente
alumno más núcleo filo es el bromuro
pero muro y después el cloruro cloruro y
hasta el final el cloruro cloruro y
sucede exactamente lo contrario si
tenemos un solvente práctico
y el fluoruro es una muy buena base
cuando logré formar un enlace con otra
molécula va a ser muy estable a
diferencia del yoduro
el yoduro es muy estable por sí mismo
pero cuando forme un enlace con algún
hidrógeno cuando tenemos yoduro de
hidrógeno esa nueva molécula no es tan
estable el yoduro de hidrógeno de hecho
es bastante ácido ok entonces la base
conjugada que es el yoduro solito no es
una muy buena base aunque hay entonces
cuando tenemos un solvente a práctico la
núcleo felicidad se va en la dirección
de la base cidad y de hecho vamos a
aprender en el próximo vídeo que la
núcleo felicidad y la base cidad están
muy relacionados pero no son
precisamente la misma cosa pero eso lo
vamos a ver pronto si estás en una
solución a práctica entonces los núcleos
y los no van a estar interactuando tanto
con el solvente por lo que el mejor
núcleo filo de los saludos es el
fluoruro después viene el cloruro
después el pero
y finalmente el yoduro si estamos en un
solvente práctico nos vamos en la
dirección de la base cidad porque este
es el mejor núcleo filo y este es el
menos núcleo filo de estos saludos sin
embargo si estamos en un solvente
práctico las cosas son exactamente al
revés este es el mejor núcleo filo y
este es el peor núcleo filo